a parte del cerebro diría que el tracto
intestinal el sistema digestivo es uno
de los órganos más inteligentes del
cuerpo porque bueno el tracto digestivo
tiene su propio sistema nervioso su
propio cerebro de hecho lo llamamos
sistema nervioso entérico porque el
tracto gastrointestinal es capaz de
actuar por sí solo sin tener que enviar
información neuronal o señales al
cerebro o la médula espinal para regular
su acción por ejemplo si tenemos delante
una comida realmente increíble algo
suficiente para cualquier héroe y la
consumimos y esa comida pasa de la boca
al esófago y aterriza en el estómago la
tenemos justo aquí lo que se inicia es
el reflejo gastro cólico gracias al
sistema nervioso entérico el reflejo
gastro cólico involucra tanto al
estómago como al colon porque lo que
pasa es que la presencia de comida en el
estómago como primera señal le dice al
colon es hora de abrirle paso a la
comida que está bajando así que el colon
como respuesta empujará hacia abajo la
comida que hay
y lo hace para dejar espacio a la comida
que estamos ingiriendo esa es la razón
por la cual después de comer tienes
ganas de ir al baño no es porque la
comida que acabas de ingerir esté a
punto de salir es porque la comida que
comiste hace un tiempo ha llegado al
final de su viaje gracias al reflejo
gastro cólico de modo que el control
neuronal es un mecanismo que utiliza
nuestro tracto gastrointestinal para
controlar lo que hacemos cuando hay
comida presente el otro componente en el
que nos centraremos aquí abajo es un
control hormonal ahora las hormonas como
recordarás son sustancias liberadas por
los tejidos de nuestro cuerpo que luego
atraviesan los vasos sanguíneos como
este para ir a algún órgano objetivo o
tejido objetivo y causar un efecto así
que voy a hablar sobre un par de
hormonas que regulan el tracto
gastrointestinal cuando hay alimentos
presentes la primera hormona de la que
vamos a hablar se llama gas trim a la
'doctrina es una hormona que se libera
cuando notamos que hay comida en el
estómago
la gástrica se libera en el estómago
para ir al torrente sanguíneo y luego
volverá el estómago para estimular la
secreción de jugos digestivos así que
recuerda que cuando tenemos comida en el
estómago esto va a causar que la
gástrica sea liberada de las células
mucosas la gástrica también causará la
secreción de un par de cosas uno las
células parietales en el estómago van a
liberar ácido estomacal o ácido
clorhídrico se va a liberar pepsi no
ajeno de las células principales del
estómago recuerda que esta es la forma
inactiva de la pepsina que debe cortarse
para activarse y poder digerir las
proteínas la otra cosa que hace la
gástrica es que aumenta la motilidad
estomacal recuerda que una de las
funciones del estómago es batir la
comida no sólo liberar ácido y pep sino
geno que van a digerir los alimentos
también descompone físicamente la comida
y el resultado es algo que se llama
quimo lo escribiré aquí el quimo esto
que el estómago enviar duodeno ahora la
liberación de gas trina en el torrente
sanguíneo presenta una inhibición cuando
la acidez del estómago alcanza un ph de
un ph bajo inhibe la liberación de gas
trina de modo que voy a decir que el
rojo es inhibición y el verde es avance
o luz verde así que recuerda que la
siguiente parte de nuestro proceso
digestivo implica enviar el quimo al
intestino delgado específicamente a la
primera parte del intestino delgado que
se llama duodeno
entonces el quimo se envía al duodeno
ahora esto va a propiciar la liberación
de otras dos hormonas la primera hormona
de la que hablaré se llama secretina una
vez que el ki-moon llega al duodeno la
secretina se libera en el torrente
sanguíneo y va a dos lugares primero va
al páncreas que podría haber dibujado
aquí en el tracto gastrointestinal está
justo aquí en el duodeno pero solo lo
voy a escribir acá la secretina va a
causar la liberación de una solución
rica en bicarbonato en el páncreas
esta solución rica en bicarbonato
involucra las enzimas pancreáticas pero
la parte más importante en la que
queremos centrarnos es en el bicarbonato
y cuál es la razón
bueno el estímulo para la liberación de
secretina fue el quimo ha sido que se
envió al duodeno
de modo que requerimos lanzar una base
como bicarbonato para neutralizar ese
ácido la secretina va a regresar del
torrente sanguíneo hasta el estómago
esto va a causar una inhibición de
motilidad estomacal de liberación de
ácido y de liberación de pepsi en ojén o
las cosas que vimos suceder con la
gástrica la otra hormona que se va a
liberar porque tenemos como ha sido en
nuestro donde no se llama col existe
quinina y como recordarás es una hormona
relacionada con la vesícula biliar y al
igual que la secretina se libera con
existe quinina de la mucosa intestinal
puedo dibujarlo viniendo de aquí a
nuestro torrente sanguíneo y también va
a ir a dos lugares uno va a ir al
páncreas para estimular la liberación de
las enzimas pancreáticas libera las
enzimas pancreáticas así que escribiré
enzimas pancreáticas y esto ayudará en
nuestro proceso digestivo una de las
enzimas que se libera del páncreas que
explicar en un minuto y ayudará a
aclarar las cosas es la lipasa recuerda
que la lipasa se usa para descomponer
los lípidos
eso es lo que significa el lip estamos
rompiendo los lípidos la otra cosa que
en la cual existe quinina va a ser es
pasar por el torrente sanguíneo y llegar
a la vesícula biliar va a ir a la
vesícula biliar y la col existe quinina
va a causar la contracción de la
vesícula biliar y qué crees que pasa
cuando la vesícula se contrae cuál es la
función principal de la vesícula biliar
bueno si recuerdas la vesícula biliar
retiene la bilis que se produce en el
hígado así que cuando aprietas la
vesícula biliar vas a bombear bilis
fuera de la vesícula biliar hacia el
conductos ístico y hacia abajo y a
través del conducto colédoco hacia el
duodeno eso ayudará a emulsionar los
lípidos y por último la otra cosa que
hace la cual existe quinina es que
regresa a este punto y disminuye la
motilidad estomacal queremos frenar la
liberación del kim o del estómago porque
necesitamos algo de tiempo para procesar
lo que ya tenemos aquí ahora es el viejo
quimo lo que causa que se libere con
existe quinina y secretean en el
torrente sanguíneo o es algo más
específico
contenido en el kimono bueno déjame
preguntarte por qué crees que se liberó
la col existo quinina si tuviéramos que
señalar un nutriente específico
contenido en el timo que requiere que la
vesícula biliar se contraiga y libere
bilis y que el páncreas libere una
enzima como la lipasa de qué tipo de
nutriente o macromoléculas piensas que
estoy hablando bueno si dijiste lípidos
tienes toda la razón son los lípidos
contenidos en el quimo lo que
específicamente hace que se libere con
existe quinina y qué pasa con la
secretina bueno de nuevo esto depende de
ti piensa en lo que sucede debido a la
secretina lo principal aquí es que se
libera bicarbonato que es una base y
hablamos de lo importante que es para
neutralizar el quimo ácido de modo que
no es realmente una macromolécula la que
hace que se libere secretina sino que es
ácido clorhídrico es la acidez del ácido
estomacal que ahora se envía al duodeno
lo que causa la necesidad de una
solución rica en bicarbonato del
páncreas es genial
creo que hasta ahora tenemos una buena
idea de cómo las hormonas
gastrointestinales nos ayudan al menos
en el tracto intestinal ahora sé que
había un pequeño grito al páncreas y
hablamos por separado sobre cómo se
libera insulina cuando tenemos un
aumento en los niveles de glucosa en el
torrente sanguíneo para ayudarnos a
almacenar esa glucosa para su uso
posterior luego ocurre lo contrario
cuando hay una disminución o niveles
bajos de glucosa y se libera glucagón
para aumentar la cantidad de glucosa en
nuestra sangre estas hormonas juntas
funcionan de una manera hermosa para
asegurar que la hormona correcta
responda al estímulo correcto así que
podemos tener comida que al llegar al
estómago sea procesada durante todo el
camino hasta el final gracias a las
hormonas y como mencionamos
anteriormente también gracias al sistema
nervioso entérico